we're feeling good great about our
contribution this cycle and we are just
getting started we're building around
the country on the ballot in Texas and
Connecticut uh and hopefully a dozen
other states by the end of this year uh
and marching towards the National
Convention next year you're going to
sneak up on this country I believe on a
forward party just sneak up like wait a
second there's six different states with
some ranked Choice action or some sane
people coming out of there let's turn
the dials down on the bad incentives
turn them up on the good uh and fix
American politics in a genuine way not
in this oh we eked out another uh wind
to survive our guy living on the edge is
no way to live sustainably
foreign
[Music]
to discuss the midterms with my main man
you know him you love him Zach growman
Zach welcome back good to be back man
I've been trying to avoid you in
politics
and failing because I show up at your
door every morning
it's a core skill of yours is convincing
people to do stuff well you know I mean
Zach's uh working on a top secret
project that will get a little bit less
top secret in the weeks to come but
we're going to unpack these midterms
what the heck just happened what the
meaning and uh effects will be so we're
recording this at a time when they're
still counting votes which they're going
to be for quite some time but we can
already tell a huge number of things so
first I want to say I was in Nevada
campaigning and yes on three Nevada is
going to be getting rid of the party
primaries and switching to non-partisan
open primaries with ranked Choice voting
up
okay big win man it's also nice to
campaign
and then win and get a video put all
that energy in and then feel the energy
and then the next day like hell yeah we
did it oh yeah I was joking with someone
else that was all because of of my
campaign I mean you know it like it it
looks like when we won the when you won
the Georgia Center Senator off you got
to take the credit for that you gotta do
are you looking by the math on that that
might have been awesome yeah big Asian
turnout for that one yeah but looking at
uh the Nevada numbers heck I mean we we
certainly helped uh so they're still
counting votes but it's looking really
really good and for those of you who are
keeping up with us at home what this
means is that Nevada is adopting the
same model that Alaska adopted in 2020
where there's no party primaries anyone
can vote for anyone winner gets decided
by ranked Choice voting it uh it
strengthens the voters though I do want
to also foreshadow that because of a
quirk in Nevada law essentially the same
ballot initiative will get run in 2024
and then after that passes the change
gets made because there's a legal Quirk
where there were two steps that need to
be taken so I will say that there's a
great chance that the forward party
National Convention is in Las Vegas
Nevada in 2024 because we need to make
sure and finish this job do it again I
personally always felt like the first
stage of this battle initiative was the
harder one so I'm pumped because a
majority of Nevada and stood up and said
yes I'd like to be able to vote for
anyone the misinformation campaigns
didn't work when I was in Nevada the
Democrats honestly were sending out text
messages being like vote no on three and
the rationale was it's too confusing
it's too cumbersome and then people were
showing me these text messages and I was
like oh man come on
um so so there'll be this negative
information campaign but I think the the
truth of it won out and I'm super pumped
and super optimistic about flipping the
switch for good in 2024 in Nevada thank
you Nevada thank you Nevada voters thank
you to everyone who volunteered to help
make that happen that's amazing big win
for four party then uh do you
I mean does it does it go in does ranked
Choice voting go into play in 2024 it
has to win in 2022
mingle around for two years and then get
voted again or does it get to start
getting implemented before then uh it
doesn't get implemented until after this
thing passed in 24 because of this this
thing goes you got to win it twice but
winning the first ones was the harder
one in my opinion for sure because again
absolutely majority of add-ins and when
I talk to these two dudes on the Strip
This was like so I was campaigning in
Nevada uh I was coming out of uh Casino
where'd you stay um I did not stay here
but I was coming out of the Cosmopolitan
because I was visiting a conference and
then there were these two Porters who
were working the front front
um of the casino hotel and then one of
them said the other hey you vote yet
it's like yeah you know and so then I
just obviously was interested so I
walked over next to them and I was like
hey guys what do you think about
question three and then the the second
guy said I'm an independent so of course
I'm voting yes on three because it means
Independence can vote in the primary and
then the first guy said uh everyone I
know is voting yes on three and from
that I thought these guys get it because
these dudes are probably belong to a
union they were uh uniformed Porters at
this casino hotel and they were just
like hey obviously we're gonna vote Yes
on three and then the the first guy then
looked at me and said hey you Andrew
Yang and I was like yesterday they did
but
um but but there was like this this
substantive
uh enthusiasm for yes on three because
they instinctively sensed it was in
their own interests yeah and then the
parties uh both came out against it but
the the people spoke the people are
right it is such a shame but it totally
makes sense that the Republicans and
Democrats like the parties don't want
what you're what you're fighting for but
yeah the parties don't want a truly open
system or unpredictability or having to
deliver for the people
accountability who wants that that makes
sense and then I saw someone comment
this on Twitter which I'm trying to
avoid I try to just scroll through or
get sports updates on but um it was
something like
it doesn't make any sense that we root
for politics like we do sports teams
yeah you know and so and actually it's
not even sports teams it's a sporting
match it's a game because it's just two
um there's not it's not even you don't
even get the 32 teams the NFL gets yeah
that's my joke is that imagine a sports
league with only two teams how do you
feel about the other uh the other team's
base I've said this many times we're
like I'm as a Bills fan Tom Brady by the
numbers objectively is probably the
greatest quarterback to ever play the
position from a resume standpoint as a
Bills fan you'll never get me to really
say that I don't care it doesn't matter
how good he is I hate Tom Brady right
he's the deflator yeah he sucks yeah
those championships weren't legit you
can go to the list but that's because
I'm a fan and so when we when you bake
fandom into things and I would I
challenge anybody listening this like if
are you a fan of are you team Dem team
Republican that doesn't mean you're
wrong it just means
there's probably some blind spots you
have you got to know you have a jersey
on yeah or you're at least gonna respond
to you know someone else's Jersey so the
the switch in Nevada
um it it made me sad that both parties
were against it um particularly the
Democrats because it does end up
reducing the uh influence of extremism
and extremists because you need to get
majority appeal to win but the parties
are okay with extremism as long as it's
their extremism well see this is part of
it is that the Democrats at the moment
uh are uh in control of Nevada but by
the way that might have changed as of
Tuesday I mean like uh you know like
um but so but if you think
more holistically you're like hey
sometimes we control things sometimes we
don't but wouldn't it be great if we
reduce the odds of crazy people
controlling yes like that that would be
a relatively uh democracy collapse yeah
like public uh spirited
um uh reception to this bad initiative
but instead it's hey
this could be bad for our party's uh
ability to lock things down so let's
spend millions of dollars in legal
challenges against the battle initiative
which they did that failed and then like
hey let's try and scare people about
this battle initiative which they tried
to do and it failed yeah um and so the
people spoke and where we're gonna make
this thing stick in 24. I will say too
that there were a lot of people that put
a lot of energy and resources behind
this battle initiative and if it had not
passed then it's gonna be tough for them
just to you know like get energized for
the next one because people are people
and if you put tons of energy and time
and resources into something that
doesn't work and then when someone comes
to you and says hey let's try it again
in another state or two states or three
states which by the way we totally want
to do in 24. right um so now you've got
a version of it in Maine a great version
of an Alaska that legitimately kept
Palin out it looks like got more it's
working it looked like yeah working all
it takes a couple of these dates like oh
wow like hey that yes then you get
Nevada and then now we can go to some
other ballot initiative States in 24
maybe even get a couple on the board at
the same time and save Western
Civilization dude huge huge win for the
forward party
um so congrats to you and the whole team
it's amazing
um this is where a lot of the real
change actually happens when it's the
blocking and tackling
like the actual when they say boots on
the ground this is actually what you're
talking about like getting signatures
getting the stuff on the ballot and
telling people about it because the
Press isn't covering it the parties are
actively trying to get rid of it it's
amazing
um it's one of the best parts about our
system that you can actually you can
actually change stuff people fight you
but you can do it
foreign
we all want to be happier healthier and
more productive and one way to do that
is to sleep better what's a concrete
thing you can do to invest in your
sleeping the best sleep of your life is
get the right mattress and Helix sleep
makes individually personalized
mattresses based upon you and your
preferences go to Helix sleep.com and
take a sleep quiz and then they will
send you a mattress that you can use for
up to a hundred nights risk-free that's
right you can sleep on something for
three months and send it back I don't
recommend it but they won't ask any
questions you don't have to take my word
for it Helix has been awarded the number
one mattress pick by GQ and Wired
Magazine and people who sleep on
mattresses for a living I don't know if
they do that but someone tested these
things and Helix was number one Helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners go to Helix sleep.com slash
Yang with Helix better sleep starts now
foreign
takeaways I had pretty quickly
um number one the odds of a trump Biden
rematch just shot up yeah because Donald
Trump's going to declare next week by
all accounts this week by the time
people hear this and
um the question was whether Joe decides
to run for re-election and if there had
been a red wave and a repudiation of uh
the Democrats and the odds of Joe
running again go down yeah but now you
can tell Joe's freaking pumped Joe did a
Victory lap for the Press Joe's like
good day for democracy people sense that
Democrats are working for them and then
when a reporter asked him it's like hey
what do you think about how the
Republicans are just going to impeach
you and do all this crazy stuff and have
hearings and investigations and then he
he played the the I'll work with anybody
card yeah
um just trying to poo poo the the
Republicans
um uh hostility
um so so Joe's feeling great yeah um
it's November
he's going to have dinner with his
family
um by all accounts Jill is apparently on
board with another run
um and so the odds of him declaring that
he's running for re-election early next
year in my mind uh just shot up and
there are a lot of people who are like
no no he's not going to do it you and I
have been around uh Joe
um the fact is it's primarily almost
solely going to be him and his family's
decision there's no one that can make
the decision for him
um but him yeah and so he's if he
decides to run you're going to see
everyone in the party establishment fall
in into line uh and so for those of you
out there being like Oh Joe can't run
again or whatnot oh he can and in my
mind the odds of him running uh now are
as high as they've ever been there's not
a lot of meat uh on the bone if you're
in the no you shouldn't run camp for
jobs like trying to have that argument
with Joe there's not a lot of evidence
for you to say you won't win or can't
win like you know people have spoken
that's that I will say this a quick note
on political Victory laps or media
Victory laps I know it's annoying like
I'm doing the Victory lap but politics
sucks so when you get the chance to take
a Victory lap you always take it you
know we did it a few times you should do
it but like you know he almost
immediately afterwards had to go on a
plane to Asia so he him doing a Victory
lap before he jetted off was like kind
of a baller move on you know I kind of
go around the country but but
um but yes the rematch that no one is
excited about seems like it's on tap
okay so Biden 2024 anything else we want
to talk about or we can also frame this
in
I wanted to do like
what's like good or what's like trending
one way and what's trending another way
yeah so um so one thing that is trending
negatively is wave elections is I think
we might be done with wave elections um
where at this point the country is so 50
50 split so I'll confess to you all in
2020 I thought it was going to be uh a
Blue Wave because people would be so fed
up with Trump his mismanagement of the
pandemic his Antics the you know the
like the just the like the the sense of
uh haphazardness
um and I was like we're going to want to
move on from this in a significant way
and house Republic house Democrats not
only didn't gain seats they lost uh I
think it was 15 seats 2020 2020. yeah uh
and I saw that and it was like wow
um that that's really surprising to me
um and so I took from that that there
was like a whole lot of latent
um uh Republican or conservative energy
and so on this one I thought that there
would be
um something of a red wave or wavelet
because of inflation and Public Safety
being in the headlines all the time and
people just being in a shitty mood
[Laughter]
there was essentially no red wave and so
what I'm realizing is that the country
has these two blocks that are almost
fixed in place and we might not see a
wave anymore because uh at this point
you're wearing a blue jersey or a red
jersey and you're gonna vote uh um now
some of the accounts of the midterms
said that it was Independence that
decided this election and depending upon
the news account they had you know 30
percent 35 percent uh Independence and
the exit polls showed that Independence
essentially split evenly uh you saw that
so so there is like this block but um
one of my takeaways was hey uh we might
not see a wave for quite some time
because at this point everyone knows
what team they're on yeah I
um what I think is trending up my
trending up was have a couple but one of
the big ones big ones was executive
leadership or let's call and there's a
lot of headline I'm not alone in this
but the quality of candidate mattered
which is so stupid in some ways to say
because it always matters but in a red
wave or a Blue Wave you know you have
idiots winning just because they're a
democratic Republican right um but you
had a couple things so
generally speaking and I think a little
more so for Republicans if they ran a
competent strong candidate with a clear
message
um they rolled and they really did roll
and that goes into santis in Florida
Brian Kemp in Georgia like rolled on
Stacey Abrams uh Abbott in Texas
um uh even you know
like I I think the ones that are
interesting is I thought Tim Ryan ran a
really good race in Ohio but JD Vance
still rolled and he was a relatively
competent Republican candidate there I
don't like I don't a comparatively to
some of the I'm not sure I'd
characterize JD that way I don't know
compared to like I I maybe but compared
to an oz or a comparative
Vance is kind of oz-ish personally
yeah but I think his Republican uh you
know I I see there's there's two sides
of that I can see the other side of it I
uh
I think he can I thought his debates
where he did a good job in the base I
think his Ohio credentials are strong
enough his Republican congratulations
are okay
um so but your general point about
candidate quality is definitely uh
accurate where there are a lot of people
bemoaning uh missed opportunities for
Republicans if they'd run different
candidates yeah like the the biggest
thing being the Senate candidate in
Pennsylvania
um the alternative to Oz who by the way
Oz only beat by something like 500 votes
was the Bridgewater CEO uh David
McClintock right and I think that
McClintock probably does perform better
um because his pennsylvania-ness
um was uh clearer yeah it's just a
different race I mean I loved fetterman
you know you don't know when the Press
doesn't love time on this particular
laugh but I love fetterman before the
stroke obviously he was a brilliant
Communicator he was on message the
problem is like
and this has nothing to do with you know
you're talking about a disability right
in this sense if it's walking or other
forms disability are different but if
you're a politician the job is to talk
right that is the job so that's I mean I
think and to synthesize information yeah
and like translate information for and
break down information for your voters
and communicate with them that's that's
what you're talking about
um so you had this you know but in that
um
in that state you had Josh Shapiro role
in the governor's race who's a high
quality candidate who's a strong
candidate so I think Executive
leadership Whitmer was pretty strong you
know two-year candidate quality Point
yeah there's this and this is something
that's pretty negative is that the
Democrat strategy of boosting
unpolitable candidates
worked in just about every instance you
talk about mastriano in Pennsylvania
they freaking boosted him yeah they
boosted Joe Gibbs in Michigan uh who
they ended up beating and Peter Meyer
would have been harder to beat even
though Peter Meyer was you know just a
lot better
um candidate and human yeah than than
Joe Gibbs Bolduc in New Hampshire they
did the same thing like the Democrats
are patting themselves in the backs
being like we're Geniuses because we
spent Millions boosting the crazy
candidates and then we managed to beat
them in the general just like we drew it
up yeah and so so anyone who we hated on
them
no no I mean it's not necessarily
because like we didn't hate on them
because it might not work tactically we
hated on them because it was if it
failed as a disaster yeah
playing with fire
and it also makes your entire hey we're
preserving democracy argument
disingenuous because most of the time
they were boosting election deniers and
extremists yes then saying like hey you
know why you can't elect those guys is
because their election deniers and
extremists like well wait they were
running against a non-election denier
who was like more reasonable but then
you didn't want to run against a
reasonable person so you you you should
the reasonable person yes
um so like we weren't [ __ ] on it
because it didn't tactically make sense
you're right um we were [ __ ] on it
because it's terrible for the public
interest and once in a while you're
going to screw up and lose to one of
these people yes
which is the opposite of what you're
saying you know the goal should be
oh boy all right so my training up want
to stick with trending up what else do
you have that's up okay so here here's
what's trending uh you can use either
trending down or trending up on this
yeah as I wrote These depending on what
Channel I guess um but here's what's
trending down
Florida and Ohio as swing States oh yeah
um because I remember a couple Cycles
ago like that was the ball game you win
Ohio and Florida then you win uh
national elections but now oh my gosh
um how many points did DeSantis win by
20 almost 20. and also uh as
compellingly last I checked Marco Rubio
beat Val demings who I regret as a
strong candidate Val Deming is a is a
good one
16 points yeah in a state that was neck
and neck well like four eight years ago
Miami-Dade County is Republican yeah
like Republicans in Florida are just
like hey sure I'm down uh you know I'm
down with uh DeSantis or Rubio or
whomever so uh if Democrats have
permanently lost Florida and I do not
see a clear path back for Democrats in
in Florida it changes the national
calculus and the same movie played out
in Ohio back to your earlier point I
thought Tim Ryan ran a phenomenal
campaign and he still lost to JD Vance
who I don't regard as a great candidate
by eight points sounds like it was it
was significant and JD Vance ran in a
fractured Republican primary and won
that primary with only 32 percent
um so JD Vance didn't have some massive
connection to the electorate that had
been demonstrated at least yep um and
Tim Ryan made a phenomenal campaign and
he still gets gets beat by how many six
points yeah six I mean six is a
non-trivial gap I mean um Republicans
won Ohio over the last couple Cycles by
800 nine points so you can say that
candidate quality Tim being good and
maybe JD Vance not being so good maybe
comprised like a three-point
um uh closing so instead of losing by
nine you lose by six but it shows that
Ohio is essentially permanently read
that to me is is uh incredibly important
um one of like the great questions I
have and this may be a real recruitment
thing for forward is that imagine being
a Dem in Ohio or a Dem in Florida and
you look up and say hey I used to have a
shot at Statewide office but now I don't
know yeah now it's a wrap
um and so like what is my future uh and
I've seen the same movie play out for uh
Democrats in in different states that
went from purple to Red so you have Ohio
and Florida becoming red States and then
the new Battlegrounds are going to be
um Michigan Wisconsin Pennsylvania which
are the traditional Midwestern states
that Trump won in 2016 that Pennsylvania
might be blue you gotta you've got their
governor rolled and fetterman was a
weaker candidate so this is why the
Democrats are feeling good though like
we have rebuilt the blue wall of
Michigan uh Pennsylvania Wisconsin right
and then added to this Nevada Georgia
and Arizona right those are the the new
six swing States but you you've written
off Ohio and Florida if you're the
national Democrats
foreign
if you're looking for a holiday gift
give the gift of reading about democracy
in my new book that's not even that new
paperback book The paperback's newish
forward notes in the future of our
democracy buy it wherever any books are
sold or you can go to fordparty.com and
pick up some swag including socks
t-shirts caps hoodies frisbees we
actually don't have frisbees all right
happy holidays
[Music]
foreign
to your point was a thing yeah or voters
are like I like this guy I don't like
this and that happens when you spend a
lot of money too
but other times where you don't know the
other names you just kind of check your
team so uh this plays into what's going
to be on everyone's mind for the next
three weeks which is going to be the
Georgia runoff which may end up deciding
uh balance of power in the Senate I
think that Warnock has an edge in this
runoff because Herschel Walker's numbers
were boosted by Governor Kemps yeah
where Governor Kemp came in well over 50
percent was uh you know 53 maybe
um and uh Walker was at 48 so this is
your ticket splitting candidate quality
thing and now you don't have Kemp on the
ticket anymore and it's just purely pure
him pure Warnock versus Walker
um I think uh Warnock probably edges it
out
um if I had to take a
um you know a guess based upon like the
level it's a pure turnout game right
that's how these work so you gotta have
people turning out for a Walker and his
character
lack or lack thereof that would be tough
well so this could end up being a
massive lightning rod for uh National
politics because if the Senate hangs in
the balance then they're going to be a
lot of national Republicans trying to
get people to care about supporting
walker uh to Mitch McConnell for those
who don't follow this it's a man who uh
is hard hard line against abortion and
has been caught paying multiple women to
uh to have a abortion for himself so uh
that's I was randomly listening to uh
talk radio on the way in today as BLS it
was a Steve Harvey Show okay and and so
Steve Harvey said like why do you want
to make Herschel Walker the your Senator
he wasn't even talking when he was in
the huddle
what it was oh that was that was funny
he was like the running back's not even
called the place
he got to the hunt so
um so it's about you know there's a
walker joke I mean there are a lot of
jokes out there
um but so but I think Warnock has an
edge and and probably right probably
squeaks out but the the political world
is likely going to be turning back to
Georgia for the next three weeks
trending up here's your thoughts
abortion rights
and I say that this is my take I'm
curious your thoughts I think it's fair
I think we can say now that abortion
rights are going to be handled state by
state
for the foreseeable future
um well certainly the the gubernatorial
and the state houses are the races
became more important because they can
make a call on abortion rights and there
have been incredibly positive signs
um in a lot of different states that if
you give it to voters they don't want to
to restrict abortion rights even in a
state like Kentucky where there's a bad
initiative and it was like hey do you
guys want a restrict abortion right so
they were like hell no and this is uh
like a fairly conservative Red State
yeah the same thing happened in Kansas
um so it does heighten the importance of
some of these State races but I'm happy
to say that if you actually pass it to
the people that they raise their hands
and say hey guys like and that goes to
show too that the entire blue red team
thing breaks down
um when you have like a concrete
decision to be made in that state it's
like do you actually want to make it so
women can't uh can't can't get anymore
Liz plank who's a um
uh let's call it activist I guess she's
been a journalist been a lot of things
um who uh I love Liz Blanca I don't
agree with her everything but she said
something she said abortion
when it's vague and emotional then
people are easily against it but when
they start to see like how that works
out in practice and how that affects an
economy and a lifestyle impacting
people's lives is awful
um which is her point which is good I
think so I went in like there's
Democrats that are going to say this was
a massive win and I think in the sense
that it it wasn't a loss like there's no
there's you're not gonna have a red wave
no there was something very cynical
about the way Democrats played the
abortion card because Dobbs comes out
and they could have actually tried to
codify Roe v Wade and have like a
um like a certain floor but they didn't
because
um they wanted to use it as a political
cudgel and you know that this is what
was going down because gosh like a month
before the midterms Joe Biden gave a
major speech being saying hey if you get
me one more Senator like will a codify
Roe v Wade and then that begs the
question it's like wait why did they do
it with the majority right like why does
one more senator make the difference for
you like it didn't make any sense but it
was clear that Democrats really want
this as a as an issue heading into the
midterms and it did pay off for them so
this is again the per version of the
two-party system in action where it's
like look
um the issue is worth more to me
unaddressed as a weapon not so that it
is addressed but I think
um there will be there will be Democrats
that claim victory like our candidates
that were strong on abortion had great
success and I don't know if that's
totally correct like Josh Shapiro
Whitmer
um for every one of those you had a Beto
or a Stacy or others um and Abbott I
mean Texas has the worst abortion laws
in the country or if not the us up there
and he he won pretty handily so um I
don't think he was on the ballot as much
because it kind of already did it but um
oh what's interesting is that I think
Democrats are feeling good because the
expectations were so negative that's
true um so to the extent there's an
expectation game
um like Republicans are sad and
Democrats are happy if you look at the
actual outcome you're essentially
looking at this deadlock polarized 55
again I mean Republicans are almost
certainly going to take the house by
some margin
um and we're in a system now where if
you have the house uh in some ways it
doesn't matter if I have it by 5 or 25
seats because if you're in the minority
party you have absolutely no say and no
power in anything because there's like
so little bipartisanship at this point
um now if Republicans have a tiny margin
which they might one of the dangers is
that their margin consists of Marjorie
Taylor green and crazy people who've
already said look if we're necessary
then we're gonna
hold up all sorts of things so you so in
in my opinion the odds of having
productive legislation emanating from uh
Congress in the next two years or
vanishingly low good because you're
going to have some version of a
republican majority in the house that
isn't going to exactly be like passing a
lot of great great stuff but because the
expectations Democrats are like few like
we did and you can't you have to say
based on historical patterns uh they
probably expected to to lose dozens and
dozens of seats
um that they didn't one thing to to know
too is that whatever happens in these
Senate races uh with um Georgia Nevada
and Arizona uh in 2024 it's going to be
very difficult almost impossible for
Democrats to hold the Senate because
there are a couple of seats they won in
2018 during a Blue Wave the last real
blue wave that are going to be almost
impossible for them to keep in 24.
specifically West Virginia
where Trump won by the 27 points in
Montana which I think is something like
plus uh nine or ten Republican
so trying to win those seats 24. yeah
it's going to be very very hard so um so
easy flips for the Republicans most
exactly so so the polarization is just
going to keep on trucking forward uh
where you're going to to now this
midterm was something of relief but like
24 is going to be upon us unfortunately
before we know it probably you know
Trump's going to announce what in a
couple days yep uh and and then the core
problems are still very much there for
us and obviously you know here at
forward our goal is to try and uh
provide like a real genuine upgrade to
our politics so it's not always this
life or death Clash uh you know
um between these two teams yep
foreign
this show is sponsored by betterhelp I
saw my first therapist when I was a
teenager and have been a huge believer
ever since and I think one of the main
barriers really is feeling like you can
reach out and talk to someone on demand
on your own time in a way that's
completely private and confidential and
affordable that's why I'm so pumped to
be sponsored by better help as the
world's largest therapy service better
help has matched 3 million people and
Counting with professionally licensed
embedded therapists available 100 online
plus it's affordable just fill out a
brief questionnaire to match with a
therapist and if things aren't clicking
you can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime it couldn't be simpler no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com Yang that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash yang
[Music]
foreign
I have a trending down trending down is
the and I'm actually I'm bringing this
up because I want to hear your thoughts
and to talk about it but the trending
down the Democratic Darlings The
Darlings of the democratic party uh
specifically
I would say Stacy Abrams and Beto
O'Rourke who both lost but lost
significantly I want to put Tim Ryan in
there I would put Tim behind too but I
don't think Tim got as much love oh he
didn't for sure uh but that's one reason
why he's so admirable yes but like I was
he's getting a lot of love now because
he did flip uh to Ohio congressional
seats it seems like or I mean you could
argue because of democratic turnout for
him he ran a good race I thought he'd
really get messaging yeah totally best
I've seen But Stacy
when I say love what do I mean by love
like Beto has been on the cover of
Vanity Fair
Stacy Abrams has been at lizzo concerts
in Atlanta
uh
go down the list uh but both lost
like wide margins right
um what do they do next and what does
that say about Democrats in a sense
because I feel like the Republican
Darlings if there is such thing
tend to win
maybe Oz wasn't a republican darling but
DeSantis for sure so this is a very big
picture question that I like
um which is what the heck do
high-profile Democrats do in states that
are unwinnable uh for in a general
election which I'm going to say at this
point
um Texas looks that way Ohio looks that
way Florida looks that way yep Georgia
does not look that way Georgia is is
clearly winnable I mean like Warnock may
win
that's like the part of Parker Stacy
he's like yeah
um but but that there is uh and this is
one of the structural deficiencies of
the two-party system is that if you are
a high profile person in one party the
other but your state is uh there's no
place for you to go and that's one of
the things I detest about the way we
practice politics in this country is
that
when you try and figure out who's going
to run for a particular position you
look around at the people who are uh at
the the level below that politically and
say which of these people has been
gearing up for that there's this entire
ladder that they're trying to to climb
and then so if you wind up in a certain
spot so I'll use Tim Ryan as an example
so Tim Ryan's member of Congress
um now there's been some redistricting
and some other problems in Ohio which
make it so that you know he may or may
not have had a path back to Congress
anyway but what is the next step if
you're him
um and so it's like well run for Senate
um and then when that step uh proves too
much uh that then you're looking up and
say okay like what is the next step for
me
um you can see it at every level where
you look and say who's going to run for
this and then you just circle around to
the half dozen folks who are like the
level below and so there's this constant
food fight for who's going to to get
like the next brass ring and and that's
the majority of the candidates we have
it it's one reason why so many folks are
hungry for someone from outside the
system because we sense that this person
do they have some deep-seated purpose to
be seeking this particular position no
since they've been in the game for X
years yeah and and the rest of it and so
like you know like look like this is the
next step for me I mean what am I going
to do be like a city council person
forever I'm gonna yeah you know take the
next step with Tim you have uh or Beto
too like but yeah so let's take a photo
member of Congress in in El Paso runs
for Senate becomes the the star because
he was running against Ted Cruz
Nationwide apparently like him in Texas
they like him enough in Texas
is like parade people people don't love
Ted Cruz he wins though he wins
um he wins every six years I mean he's
not sure you won in 2018. um but so so
that it's tough because there's no
natural next step for these people yes
uh and so what often happens with people
of a certain profile and you know I've
been in this bucket too actually where
you know what you do as like your
holding pattern talking headed
like some of the folks will be like get
tabbed by uh particular media Network
and say hey and so one very very real
possibility of this is certainly Stacey
Abrams like you know will Stacey Abrams
get a call from MSNBC being like hey hop
on TV and like do stuff but these are
things that only apply to folks who are
relatively high profile and and so the
the thing that I see all the time is
that people are getting up and outed uh
in our two-party system politically
because there's just no place for them
to go where they are it's one reason why
what we're doing it Forward I think is
so important is because we can provide a
long-term home and breeding ground for
people who want to do positive things in
their Community where uh you can
actually stay in the doing good stuff
Pursuit
um even if there isn't necessarily like
you know a a spot for you in terms of
the next rung of elected politics
um and and this is one of the diseases
too is that what does the Press do well
we'll just follow the relative Rises and
fall of like the these different people
you know what I mean it's like oh this
person's trending up this person's
trending down yes and and you know we're
human so we're like oh like I want to
keep track of who's trending up and down
meanwhile the entire system is like you
know becoming increasingly ridiculous
and unproductive
but like you know but but we'll all just
get sucked into the character drama and
like oh show me a video of some [ __ ]
doing something I hate like yeah I hate
this person and then it's like oh let me
um let me vote against them let me
donate against them and that's like the
the you know it's like this career path
like Tim Ryan he goes and he runs for
they tell you oh you're in Congress like
why don't you run for president I'm sure
they told us to swallow well and Joe
LeBron oh God they never told them to
run for president you're [ __ ] kidding
I'm sure I'm certain political advisors
I'm not telling like the powers that be
but like their political advisors like
run for president you'll boost your
National profile you'll get some press
you'll get on a debate stage people will
see you and then when you run for Senate
in two years or a year and a half then
you you have a national donor base
you've met all these big players you
have people to pull money from and then
the national like the party will love
you because you're challenging you know
a seat they want to win et cetera I mean
that's what I mean it's what happens and
you just kind of get left at the end I'm
not sure what you do uh I don't know
what Tim Ryan does next so this does
raise a very important question which is
we opened this discussion talking about
how the odds of uh Trump Biden shot up
because of this midterm on CNN the other
day uh I said hey there's no way the
Democrats run a genuine primary uh if
Joe runs for reelection where if if Joe
says hey I'm running for reelection in
theory the Democrats have to have a
primary and people can challenge him but
no one in the establishment is going to
challenge Joe you'll have a you'll have
someone on the left I'm sure give it a
shot well so so this is what I said on
air I I said the DNC is going to pull
the plug on any process because there is
no way that they are going to have their
81 year old president
debate Nina Turner six times yes uh
which is the way it would play out if
you actually had like a a positive row
would row do it I don't know if he's
still he's a little establishment so so
people who are in The Establishment uh
aren't going to touch it because it's
going to become this massive litmus test
of like look like are you really going
to enable Trump to win yeah um by
challenging our guy Joe even though you
know a majority of Americans and
Democrats be deeply concerned about
running a soon-to-be 82 year old
um for president again
um after doing that most grueling job in
the world for four years but you're
going to see just crickets when
everyone's like hey who wants to run
against Joe like everyone's gonna be
like you know anyone who actually is
within the Democratic party and and
imagines they have a future within the
Democratic party will not challenge Joe
so you know who would challenge him
Marianne Williamson Nina Turner yes
someone of that ilk
um just a total aside I think Tulsi
gabbard runs for president on the other
side as Republican yes okay
um probably so so I don't see Tulsi in
this this field of potential Challengers
uh for Joe but the DNC looks at this and
says there is absolutely no way we're
going to to have Joe uh be contested by
um these folks so they're going to to
short-circuit the process maybe they'll
say hey we'll have a debate if uh if
someone breaks 20 and then if someone
like Marianne or Nina got to 20 they
would just change the dial and be like
hey I meant 30. yeah
and and they'll be this so the RNC did
this in 2020 by the way that they had
trumped the incumbent president he was
challenged most people don't remember
this by uh Joe Walsh and uh um Bill Weld
and some other people yeah uh and then
the states just started canceling their
primaries
[Laughter]
because it's the Republicans and Trump
and they're like yeah of course those
guys don't follow the rules but uh but
the Democrats will in my opinion do the
same thing because they don't want to
weaken Joe uh ahead of his rematch with
Trump
but here so here's the other thing um I
wrote a chapter on this my book and I
didn't publish it because it's part of
it but to a for the Democratic
establishment which really means it
means a couple things but a lot of it
means political Consultants Biden's a
dream you have right now we have an
economy that most people say is not
doing well you have inflation that
people do not like we have crime that's
pretty much up
in every major city uh that is a top
issue for most of the country and you
have presidential approvals and vice
presidential approvals that are not good
um
yet he still had the best
like the best performance of an
incumbent's political party
um or at least projected right now since
you know we rallied around the flag
after 9 11 in 2002. so that's a dream if
you because it's just the Democrat like
like team Biden's feeling to the team
Dems like we keep our political
consultants in Talking Heads in power
um Republicans don't have a real strong
message per se to fight even like if the
economy's bad enough the Republicans had
a good message they should have won a
lot more seats the question I want to
ask you is I think uh DeSantis 2024 is
ramping up and I don't think DeSantis
runs if Trump runs and I think Trump's
going to declare Trump's going to
declare that's like the rumors yeah yeah
they're like rumors like sourced by his
team so I I made reference to the two
Fields so the Democratic primary if Joe
runs for reelection I think it barely
exists and that there's not a true
process
um Republicans I mentioned Tulsi Chris
Christie Larry Hogan Mike Pence Mike
Pompeo Trump
uh
maybe uh Mary Suarez in Miami
um if all those people run DeSantis
wouldn't make sense it wouldn't make
sense from an edge of that field because
you know they would all steal from him
they probably wouldn't steal from Trump
it's the same moderate Republican vote
right yeah so so I I think I got to
seven candidates
um and and there were some I did not
name there will be more but there will
be more so if you have Trump and his
let's call it 40 to 50 hanging out there
and then everyone else breaking up the
other 50 yeah
um if you're DeSantis
you just sit on it for a cycle uh and
and then it just comes to you you're a
parent you get all the money like Trump
you might put him as VP yeah yeah like
Trump runs and and you're you're like
you know like succeeding as Governor
then like you know if Trump loses then
you're the next person up and everyone's
waiting for you and everyone's happy if
you run against Trump uh you wind up
factoring the base get a lot of negative
energy I mean Trump is very very uh
vindictive it's negative press all day
long and and vengeful you end up taking
your relatively robust base right now
and splitting it in two and then uh you
emerge really really tattered
um maybe it's like that's the cost
benefit like you know especially because
DeSantis has been telling donors that
he's not going to run against Trump at
least that's what he was saying X weeks
ago so um but these little people don't
think rationally like we've done
cost-band analysis I could have done a
cost band analysis on half the
Democratic field last time like that the
cost would say Don't run for president
um oh you're kidding the the field last
time was wide open I think anyone
whoever salt should have like gotten
into that race that we were in I agree
um my my bigger point was
if you're the Republicans the
Republicans are better at lining up than
Democrats are and I would say save for
2020 the Democrats don't typically
easily line up behind a candidate
um the the joke would be you know
Democrats fall in love Republicans fall
in line is what we would say in the
campaign if you're Republicans knowing
you had already lost to Biden
four years ago do you really run it back
again under Trump
or today is there not enough power to
stop that if you were if you were to
have a bunch of Republicans say hey
would you prefer that Trump not run they
tell you it's like yeah I prefer he
doesn't run but after Trump declares
what are you gonna do yeah and the
reason he's declaring early he's like I
don't want you guys to joining it's my
party or what what someone said was that
um like Trump controls the primary but
then he's attacks in the general but
then the primary comes first so what are
you gonna do and then if you run against
him you you know probably get
steamrolled so uh so this Dynamic is
playing out uh the the question still
remained the same even though this
midterm uh I think was
um relatively benign for a lot of people
and I'm going to close with one other
bright spot for forward and as we're
having this conversation we're not quite
sure but Adam Frisch in Colorado might
have beaten Lauren bobert
um who's not cool and this is something
I'm particularly proud of because Adam
this is a district that no one was
paying any attention to Dems didn't want
it yeah well it was deep red so they're
like uh like why run someone but um Adam
Frisch got enlisted to run third party
uh endorsed him and backed him
uh and did what we could to help him and
it looks like he might uh get rid of
Lauren bobert
um which would be a victory for common
sense and rationality in the the country
but also it shows that even in a deep
red District a lot of people that
weren't down with Lauren bobert as the
ideological uh you know talking head
it's like you know what I kind of just
want a member of Congress I kind of want
someone who might you know actually do
something so 50 50 right now 95 96 96 in
so thank you to everyone who uh
supported Adam or supported forward
because that's the kind of thing we're
actually making happen in real life you
know what I mean like um like the the
national Democratic party ignored this
race because they were like you know
look we're a dollars and cents party
we're not going to spend money in a race
that we don't think we have any chance
of winning
um but but but forward uh endorsed Adam
and uh because it's the right thing to
do
um we're actually in touch with him and
help get them into the the race even
that's um a huge win man and so it'd be
a huge win and so it's a win that year
this is this close right yeah yeah so
regardless what we're feeling great
about it
um so uh from the forward perspective
um and we didn't talk much about it
thank you Evan McMullen for running a
great race we'll probably have Evan uh
on to talk about
um his race and what the future holds uh
thank you thank you thank you to
everyone who helped get Nevada a huge
step closer to non-partisan primaries
and ranked Choice voting and for
boosting the 9 fine forward party
endorsed candidates like Adam frischer
it looks like might have won their races
you know like we're feeling good great
about our contribution this cycle and we
are just getting started we're building
around the country on the ballot in
Texas and Connecticut uh and hopefully a
dozen other states by the end of this
year and marching towards the National
Convention next year what a moment man
no one's going to you're going to sneak
up on this country I believe on a
four-party just sneak up like wait a
second there's six different states with
some ranked Choice action or some sane
people coming out of there let's turn
the dials down on the bad incentives
turn them up on the good and fix
American politics in a genuine way not
in this oh we eked out another uh wind
to survive our guys moving on the edge
is no way to live sustainably yes uh you
know what you want to do is have a
rational system that we can all like
sleep on easily and not just be at the
edge of our seats every [ __ ] cycle
amen some wins for Ford is exciting
thanks for having me on man it was fun
thank you Zach we'll have you back all
the time the people have spoken the
people love Zach we got everyone in
doses you know what I'm saying
beautiful love you guys